-Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite Fall songs
from you guys, and here
to help me out and sing them
is one of our guests tonight.
As I said, her new album,
"Beautiful Trauma,"
comes out tomorrow.
Ladies and gentlemen, Pink!
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Oh, my!
-I love you, I love you!
Pink, thank you for being here.
We --
We love you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on.
That's what I'm talking about.
Uh...
[ Cheering continues ]
All right,
these are Fall-themed songs.
Pink, are you ready for this?
-I think so.
-All right, here we go.
This first one
is from @rockatbrock.
-Rocket Brock.
-Not Rocket Brock.
RockAtBrock.
-Oh, he's at Brock.
-Not Rocket Brock.
-Oh, 'cause I know Rocket Brock.
-That's like a term --
-Yeah, "Hey, rock it, Brock!"
-"Yo, rock it, Brock."
-No, this is RockAtBrock.
-Okay.
-He says...
♪♪
-♪ Fall is here ♪
♪ To remind you ♪
♪ Of the allergies
you thought went away ♪
♪ Fall don't care ♪
♪ If it's colder ♪
♪ 'Cause you've got to breathe
that Autumn air ♪
♪ Ahh, ah-choo ♪
♪ Blow your nose ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What?!
-Come on!
-What's going on?
-Whoa!
-What are you doing?
That's unbelievable!
The Roots and Pink
have to release that.
-They rock it, Brock.
-Oh, I love it.
Rock it, Brock.
This one is from @JWittle87,
and she says...
♪♪
-1, 2, 3...
-♪ Ain't no blower
strong enough ♪
♪ Ain't no rake sturdy enough ♪
♪ Ain't no trash bag
big enough ♪
♪ To keep me from
jumping in leaves, babe ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Keep me from
jumping in leaves, babe ♪
Man, you are so good.
Oh, my gosh.
This one is from @carec11carec.
She says...
♪♪
-♪ Every branch you shake ♪
♪ Every leaf you rake ♪
♪ Every pie you bake,
every punt you fake ♪
♪ I'll be lovin' Fall ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I can't take it.
I can't take it.
-It's like a concert.
-I could do this the whole show.
-This is unbelievable.
I'm freaking out right now.
-Oh, my God!
-This is so great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You are so good.
All right, this one --
This is from @LyshaaG.
-LyshaaG?
-Yeah, there's, like,
a couple A's there.
-Not Lysha G.
-So it's like Lyshaa...
-G.
-Like, "What's up, G?"
-It's like, "Rock it, Brock."
[ Laughter ]
But instead of "Rock it,
Brock," you say...
-Rock it.
-Lyshaa, G.
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @LyshaaG.
-Rock it, Brock.
-She says...
♪♪
-♪ Oh, I got friends
in corn mazes ♪
♪ Where the cider drowns,
and the candy chases ♪
♪ My blues away ♪
♪ I'll jump in hay ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
I love it!
I would --
You have to do these songs!
I love every one of these songs.
-Come on!
It's like a concert.
-Your voice is amazing!
I would buy
every one of these.
I love all of these.
[ Light laughter ]
This one's from @radiogurlmel,
and she says...
-1, 2...
-♪ Big trees
are made of leaves ♪
♪ Who am I to disagree? ♪
♪ I travel the world
for the pumpkin seeds ♪
♪ Everybody's
just waiting for Santa ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ooh!
Ooh!
-Rock it, Brock!
-I love that one, too!
I love that one, too.
This one is from @Amymeck.
She says...
♪♪
♪ I'm a tricker, I'm a treater ♪
♪ I'm a Reese's eater ♪
♪ I get my candy on the run ♪
♪ Ooh, ooh, ooh ooh ooh ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh!
Come on.
-Come on!
Come on!
-She is fantastic.
-Those harmonies were tight.
-That was good.
Those harmonies were good
on that one.
I know, exactly.
You know,
some people call me Maurice.
-Whoo-hoo!
[ Light laughter ]
This one is from
@caromontesquieu.
-Montesquieu?
-Yeah, it is Montesquieu.
-Isn't it?
Like, old-timey.
I've only heard that
in old-timey comics.
-But how would you know that
that's how it was spelled?
I mean, you can't see it
from there.
-I saw it on the cue card
over there.
[ Laughter ]
Right over there.
-I forget we have cue cards.
[ Laughter ]
I was like...
-Got the jump on you, dude.
-"How did he even guess that --
Yeah, you're right.
-I rocked it, Brock.
-It is spelled Montesquieu.
[ Laughter ]
-Lyshaa, G.
-This one here
is from @caromontesquieu.
-Oh, good.
[ Laughter ]
I love her.
Love her.
-And she says...
♪♪
♪ Lil' witch ♪
♪ You can't trick with me
if you wanted to ♪
♪ These expensive,
these is orange bottoms ♪
♪ These is pumpkin shoes ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow!
[ Laughing ]
-Come on.
These is...orange bottoms.
Oh, my gosh.
This is great.
This last one is from --
-Oh.
-Is a song from Pink,
and it is from @rassmusenkandi.
She says...
♪♪
♪ Just give me Fall season ♪
♪ Just a little bit of fun ♪
♪ Just a second
to enjoy this weather ♪
♪ Before it's wintertime again ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-There you have it.
There you have it!
Those are our
"Tonight Show Hashtags"!
[ Cheers and applause ]
My thanks to Pink!
We are talking to her
a little later in the show.
You are the best.
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.